kurden präsident massud barsani tritt
zurück irakische militär und schiitische
milizen rücken in umstrittene gebiete
vor die vom kurdische peschmerga
gehalten werden heute in frecher kompakt
das unabhängigkeitsreferendum der kurden
und dessen folgen am 25 september hatte
sich eine mehrheit von mehr als 90
prozent für die unabhängigkeit des
kurdischen gebieten im irak
ausgesprochen
das war nicht zum ersten mal schon 2005
gab es ein ähnliches votum mit auch
gleich der zustimmung durch diesmal
diesmal war der zeitpunkt ein anderer
denn schließlich hatte man gemeinsam mit
den usa und anderen erfolgreich gegen
den as gekämpft mann hatte vom westen
moderne waffen und ausbildung erhalten
man hatte umstrittene gebiete einnehmen
können vor allem das gebiet um die erde
stadt kirkuk und man hatte mehr als zwei
millionen flüchtlingen zuflucht geboten
man hatte sich sozusagen als treuer
verbündeter des westens erwiesen und
konnte eine gegenleistung erwarten
die reaktionen auf das referendum waren
aus jüdischer sicht ernüchternd bis
schockierend der westen und die usa
bemängelten den zeitpunkt der selbst
schwer da es noch geschlagen werden
müsse und der einfluss des iran
zurückgedrängt werden müsse manche haben
überhaupt kein problem mit
separatistischen bewegungen man denke
nur an spanien und katalonien die
nachbarschaft reagierte heftig die
türkei drohte mit militärische maßnahmen
der iran mit einem wirtschaftsboykott
und der vollen unterstützung für bagdad
bagdad selbst die regierung wies den
luftraumsperren isolierte quasi die
region und schickte kräfte in marsch um
die umstrittenen gebiete zu besetzen
oder zurückziehen
kurz zu den gebieten man kann sich hier
drei zonen vorstellen zone eins ist das
kerngebiet das in der autonomie
verankert wurde und auch heute völlig
unbestritten ist
zone 2 gehört nicht zum kerngebiet ist
aber mehrheitlich von kurden besiedelten
zone 3 ist jenes große gebiet das sie im
kampf gegen den islamischen staat
erobert wurde
das aber keine kurdische mehrheit
aufweist interessant war das iranische
vorgehen ist nach wie vor fokussiert auf
die zone 3
und es hat zu heftigen streitereien
zwischen den kurden geführt dass kirkuk
kampflos übergeben wurde
was war nun die absicht hinter diesem
referendum wie kann man drei dimensionen
unterscheiden dimension 1 innerhalb des
irak innerhalb der kurden wo es um den
führungsanspruch geht weil die pkk immer
stärker geworden ist und die gruppe um
bazany dann vielleicht zuvorkommen
wollte innerhalb des irak ist es um
verhandlungsmasse gegangen weil hier die
starke position vielleicht in
verhandlungen über die zukünftigen
rechte in irak eingebracht werden konnte
regional ist es um den präsident
charakter gegangen können die kurden aus
dem nordirak eine führende rolle
einnehmen oder kann das vorbild der
unabhängigkeit eine auswirkung haben auf
die kurden in den anderen nachbarstaaten
alle drei dimensionen sind hier
vermutlich erfasst insbesondere dann
wenn es in richtung unabhängigkeit gebe
erste erkenntnisse aus dem referendum
und den reaktionen ist besteht ein
starker wunsch nach unabhängigkeit bei
der kurdischen bevölkerung aber auch
nach normalität und frieden
es besteht keine politische
geschlossenheit in der politischen
führung der kurden und die regierung in
bagdad fühlt sich stark sie scheint auch
eine militärische auseinandersetzung mit
den kurden nicht die ablehnung in der
region war vermutlich wesentlich stärker
als das von kurdischer seite eingesetzt
wurde und vermutlich hatten sich
wesentlich mehr unterstützung von
westlicher seite erhofft als tatsächlich
eingetreten ist was ist daher zu
erwarten die unabhängigkeit wird in
absehbarer zeit nicht zu erzielen sein
aber der rückzug von präsident barsani
kann als politisches allgemeine signal
verstanden werden für einen neubeginn
mit bagdad für eine einbeziehung der
kurden in allgemeine irakische
politische belange für mehr mitsprache
der westen ist dabei in der pflicht denn
die kunden haben sich als verlässlicher
partner beim kampf gegen den usa wiesen
und der westen sollte sich nun als
verlässlicher partner bei der zukunft
der politischen zukunft der kurden im
irak gewesen
[Musik]